feel good hey everyone this is jaclyn
fernandez and welcome to the feels good
podcast
yes and i am amanda cerny and our guest
today
is the jet setting supermodel successful
author
award-winning sought after dietitian and
the mother of
three very successful children including
a genius
elon musk and also tosca musk who has
started
passionflix which all of you have to
check out amazing amazing films
and kimball musk who i also have worked
with before with big green
doing big things with big rain and she's
also the cover
of the new york magazine in 2011 hit the
runway for new york fashion week in 2016
and held
four billboards in times square which
wow
may have been a world record at the time
also
and became an ambassador for covergirl
in 2017 at age
69. she did it all while starting over
in eight different cities across
three countries and two continents while
raising three children as a single
mom her indomitable spirit and yes i can
attitude made her a global success story
in the prime of her life
please welcome the ageless timeless and
seamless
so inspirational oh my gosh thank you so
much for being on our show mate
i admire both of you i think you're
working so hard and
it's great work i'm i love following you
on instagram
oh thank you may no we we're just trying
to be like you
yeah i want to see you we're just trying
to copy you we're just trying to live
your life
that's why we want to hear all your
stories so we can literally just apply
it to our own lives
and be where you're at yeah
where where in the world are you right
now because i know you're such a jet
setter
i'm in los angeles you're moving back to
new york next year
what you know i moved to angelis because
tosca had twins seven years ago
and when she uh so she needed me to help
her and she said you can't go back to
new york so i had to sell the apartment
and move to la
but now she's moving to atlanta georgia
because they have better
tax credits for films and then yeah elon
moved to uh texas so i'm not going to be
here alone i don't have to be i'll go
back to new york where most of my
friends are
oh so do you you so you prefer new york
to l.a
yes you're you're new york girl i like
the east coast
too i have so many great friends and
they i would visit them often i mean
because i was flying to new york
twice twice a month for work you know
other modeling was speaking engagements
and then of course i did my big book
launch in new york
so um so i mean they they all thrilled
on coming back
but may you've traveled so much
where would you say is one of your
favorite places
to go to um i still i love so many
places
you know i had a great time in china and
i love a great time in india a
great time in hungary i love london
and england you know and then
i left canada of course i was born in
canada
the the accent is because my parents
moved to south africa when i was two
and i was and then i moved back to
canada at uh
41 yeah because my kids wanted to go
there
wow yeah so um you know you make moves i
mean
i don't purposefully move cities but you
you move a city big or country because
you're getting out of a bad situation
or you want to get into a more
interesting or better situation
and each move is painful i don't know
how many times you've moved
have you moved a lot i have
really yeah you've done um you
you were based where first amanda oh
well mine was within the states i'm not
as like uh
i wish i could say it was like south
africa canada
but mine was uh just pennsylvania
connecticut iowa
new york florida and that's still a lot
yeah but each move is traumatic because
things go wrong
so you plan you plan your move and then
the truck doesn't come and then
your things break and then you're
packing things wrong and
it happens and then you connect you go
to the next place the electricity
doesn't work and the taps don't work and
you know it's each time there's pro
there's drama
and that's so funny maybe because you're
moving again next year
i feel so nicely planned and of course
that
a woman makes a plan isn't my book even
yeah
so i know there's going to be delays or
there's going to be changes and
all sorts of things you never you know i
just have to but there's there's also
such a thrill in it as well right it's
also there's something exciting about
i'm moving house like i've only really
ever moved house i i did the major shift
to
india when i was in when i was about 21
um and then here i've just really just
been moving house and next week i moved
to
a house and that's like really exciting
me right now
where did you move from so i was
well yeah i did um i grew up in the
middle east so that was in bahrain
um i studied there i schooled there and
then i did my university in australia in
sydney
which i loved um
yes and then i interned in sri lanka
that's where my father's from so i
interned there at a tv station
um a youth station a youth tv station
uh for like about a year and then post
that it was just straight to india
to do some modeling um
didn't think it would turn into acting
it did eventually turn into acting and
then
i've just been here ever since so again
we've all
moved so much yes yeah yeah
now we can virtually chat and check
happened
and yes it was impossible to be able to
do this before and now all of a sudden
everyone's in different parts of the
world
chatting away it doesn't matter what you
know which country you're living in
soon probably what planet you'll be
living in
excitingly you started modeling at such
a young age
i mean you know um i i know
me and amanda have also started like we
started working super young but you
started modeling at around 15.
so this is when you were in canada no
then i was still in south africa i was
at school
my mother's friend had a modeling school
and she said
gave me a free modeling course and i
said what i don't care i was a science
nerd you know i didn't think about
things like that
although i liked fashion i would make my
own clothes because
in south africa fashion was six months
behind so when i wanted to make bell
bottom pants or mini skirts
i pretty much you can't buy them so i
would make it myself
and wow my mom taught us how to sew and
then she sent me to pattern cutting so i
could buy a pattern and then cut it
uh cut it to um to suit the new fashion
so then i did like fashion and then i
did the modeling course and then the
next thing she says
i need you to do a runway show and book
me for one and then she paid me and i'm
saying what
what clothes and walk around
and that's when it started but i didn't
let it interfere with my studies because
of course
it was just kind of a hobby and i would
then just do the
runway shows evenings or weekends but
yeah and anyway schooling schooling was
very strict in south africa
there's no way you take off for for a
modeling job
and then i went on to do a bachelor of
science degree and again the model
continued which is
so bizarre because they really weren't
using models
older than 18 and i was getting up to 21
already yeah
at 20 years i won beauty competitions
yeah
so which 21 was considered old at that
time like 40.
oh yeah for 18. pretty much at 18
uh after 18 you were considered quite
old
but now you're now 72 yeah
did you notice a a change in that
mentality though
like throughout the years like has that
kind of stuck around of like oh
like 21 is a little bit old for modeling
and then
nowadays do you feel that's still the
same
thought process well you know when i do
runway shows i'll be the only whitehead
uh
older model and it'd be sometimes 150
young models and they all want selfies
with me because they all think they're
getting to 20 and maybe nobody will book
them again
so when they see me then they say
there's hope for us
there is hope yeah exactly i love that
yeah i mean definitely an inspiration
and also like
paving the way for so many other women
that you know
really enjoy that career and that's what
they want to do and
taking off those limitations that are
kind of like put on them
because i i feel like i feel like a lot
of agencies even like when they sign new
models like the first thing they they're
like all right well we gotta get you to
work because
you tick tick tick tock yes we always
say that like
i mean for me as well being an actress
when i first started it was like listen
do as many films as you can
um do whatever you can because actresses
have a shelf life actresses have a shelf
life
and um it was always like when you're if
you're over 30
you know you can slowly start phasing
out because acting's not for women over
30 years old
and you know then it's of course like
you have these amazing women
i mean like there's there's meryl streep
and you know
um i mean not to say
yesterday they're all doing such amazing
work
but like and i do really believe and i
want to believe this as well that the
world is changing
and there's so much more space for just
all sorts of different
just people different from different
nationalities
um just gender sex all that kind of
stuff age
um but uh yeah it just starts with
certain people and one of them is you
for sure me i really feel like you have
really set the bar for so many things
and paved the way
yes i would say
you know tosca has her own platform
called passionflix which is a
available worldwide and she takes
best-selling romance novels and makes
them into movies
she made a movie with where the couple
fall in love and they're in their 50s
and i was so happy about that so you
know
and they all love stories
and and then she does a different uh um
she it's very varied her uh um
movies uh a gay couple uh
interracial couples you know um you know
a movie with all black people because he
always
was black and i don't know if you could
if black is insulting in in
india or because they're not saying
south africa because
um they aren't all african-american some
of them
are english are they in english i don't
know what they say in
england if they say uh that's an african
english
person i don't know you know you have to
be very careful now with
saying anything of course you upset
someone
yeah but yes that she has this variety
of uh of of actors and that they're
definitely indian
actors in it and yeah i mean like that's
doing that even before it was like um
it's so weird to call it a trend because
it should be something that we always do
all the time and she's been doing it
even before it was like
in the news as like and now everybody
cares like she was including
showing representation for all different
types of people
and you know kind of like paving the way
like you're paving the way yourself
and your sons are like how how did you
create this
how did you do this oh gosh
i i just have the best kids ever they
really care about
other people and care about the planet
and
with with tosca's movies by the way it's
female directors
and women get paid the same as the men
and
age is not a problem obviously because
she's putting me in as an extra this off
uh i'm doing a shoot at a gala with her
uh today um i don't always do that
because i'm
busy around the world oh my gosh
a week you know before everybody gets
tested for covered
yeah so it's just great now the thing is
when women are
ignored or they said 30 or 40 you're
over with
who's telling you you're over with it
because if it's a female telling you
then that's
not right women should be supporting
women of all ages
but if not telling you then you have to
form your own company
and show that women are powerful and
intelligent and
and and capable you know and that's why
if people are are telling you you're
getting old for movies
then it's usually a man and
then you start your own company and you
make sure that
that content absolutely that is that is
actually what a lot of people and but
you know like right now that is actually
what what quite a few actresses have had
to do and i think
um in hollywood as well like if you take
a look at what reese witherspoon
has been doing the best yeah
he's been so inspiring because like
that's exactly it's i know even here
it's inspired so many women to do the
same thing and they're like you know
what okay they're not making roles for
us
um if they've stopped making rules for
us and it's just like
we're kind of out of work why don't we
just do it ourselves
and quite a lot of like actresses have
been doing that it's also
it seriously inspired me to like also
think of doing something for myself
and uh just be able to tell the stories
that we want to be able to tell because
if no one's going to be writing them for
us then we're the only ones who can
actually like you know
make that difference and do what we can
we should do something with tosca
yes we should all get together and like
come up with like an amazing story and
tell us great
idea oh my goodness yes
i kind of want to dive into because i
mean you have
two master degrees one in diet like
dietitian and lots of science did we say
here i was this i'm a science nude and
then i would model part-time but i
didn't tell people or anything
and then when i got married i had three
kids in three years that don't recommend
that that's hard work you're pretty
branded
yeah and when i was 28 and they wanted
me to
be model uh mother of the bride so again
i did that but i had a private practice
and i never let them
i mean people who'd come to see me for
doctors would send their patients to me
for diabetes or heart disease or
or just eating well you know losing
weight mainly
and i just i never let them know that
i'm a model but sometimes they'd bring a
magazine is this you you know and i say
yes i do that sometimes
because you need to focus on the patient
you don't focus on yourself and
i'm so fabulous
and so so i supported my kids mainly as
a dietitian
and then i modeled part-time it's only
when i became a supermodel
that when i moved to new york and i did
these huge tv commercials that
uh my then my modeling would get a
little priority because i got paid
better
whereas before that in uh
in canada and south africa the payment
was the same so i wasn't encouraged to
go to modeling
and i would um and i would make sure
that my modelling job
covered his mac paid as well as the as
the nutrition
is missing a day's work in in with my
with my clients you know so i had to
calculate things you know well
yeah no no
can you get some can we get some free
nutrition advice from you
yeah no it's all in my book is it i
follow
common sense and science because i have
to follow science because i
have two masters of science degrees and
i have to follow what the evidence shows
is the best diet
so the best artwork they're showing is
the mediterranean diet
is number one the dash diet which is
a hypotense of that which is similar the
flexitarian diet
and that's what i follow which is
vegetarian at home and then meat fish or
chicken
outside and then i'm okay pieces back
and then i'll have some more
because i'm not a great cook anyway and
then the weight watchers start so
they're just basically
eating real food and um
yeah and limiting the um the fried
chicken the burgers
and the desserts which i love and now i
know
i love the sweets too but it doesn't
even look like you have a sweet
tooth like you're just like in the best
shape
ever well i i i
was a plus size model actually for 10
years i gained 30 kilograms or 65 pounds
and because i just said um you're well
my fiance had gotten somebody else
pregnant and moving next door to me
and the wedding invitations were all
printed and i wouldn't send them out and
so um i felt very sad and i ate my way
through that one
gosh she had pre-dessert at the time and
i thought
well at some stage i'll stop gaining
weight but you actually don't stop
gaining weight if you eat like that you
gain weight
and i was getting to 40 years old and my
cholesterol went up and my back and my
knees were hurting
and i said well i'm either going to go
on drugs and painkillers
or else i'm going to have to eat better
and i am a dietitian i lectured on it
i would give people i'll tell them do
what i tell do what i say don't do what
i do
you know because i'm very funny but um
obviously i'm right and clever
then i lost the weight and i've kept it
off for 30 years
and in my home they on there are no
no sweet foods at all because yeah one
slow day or one
bad news day which is daily you know the
news is always so bad
and i would finish off a box of
chocolates so ah
a stress eater like yeah but that's so
great
honestly i know i know that's not a
great thing but like it's so great to
hear that you're like that because
i'm a stress eater as well i you know
there's so much pressure right at work
and um
and sometimes you just have a terrible
day i live alone so for me it's like if
there's something in my fridge i've come
back home
to an empty house and i'm alone oh my
god help me like
so i do like i i ban them from my house
yeah i think that's kind of
a big solution for everyone you know if
you have something that you love that
you pick up in the grocery store that
you know is not
probably the best thing for you but you
love it you're gonna
eat it at some point and then you're
gonna get more because you ate it and
then it just it's a cycle
so just like i think that's what helped
me a lot
too and i know may like it's not
i don't like i i know vegan probably
isn't meeting like the mediterranean
diet but
whenever i veganism really helped me
cut out a lot of the stuff that i ate
way too much of
like the dairy i was like cold turkey
no more dairy because i was just eating
like a
freaking whole thing
wedge of cheese i would i would travel a
lot to europe and
every time i would go through amsterdam
i would just get like the aged cheese
and like
get pounds and pounds of it and i just
eat oh yeah
amanda has vegan cheese yeah which is
good
like some of it's processed so yeah no
vegan foods can be very processed and
you know you
you have to do what works for you if you
i had vegan patients
and i would have to they could still be
obese if they ate
vegan cookies and fries and drank too
much wine
you know yeah it wasn't that vegan made
you slim but
obviously you have the formula around
but you still need to balance it well
for yourself
now when it comes to delicious cheese i
don't have that in my
fridge either i have very plain cheese
that you don't die for i mean bring me a
brie and i'll finish off the whole
oh bring it on
and so i don't have a return but if i do
go out i can overeat
a lot and then i know i'm getting three
pounds overnight and i have
like a week i have to eat perfectly
again to drop those three pounds because
otherwise it stays on you
yeah and i think that balance is so good
too because it's not like to say
you can never have what you crave ever
in life and you're just stuck to
land things like in your prime example
of that you still eat what you enjoy but
in moderation
so yes but if you bring me a tub of ice
cream i eat the whole topic
you know i have no control in there
don't bring me
any ice cream well these things all
right that's like a drug
so i mean when people say they died of a
drug overdose i said
well i would die of a chocolate overdose
yeah
which is because it's delicious way to
go you know but
yeah that's that's your drug of choice
that's mine
chocolate yeah
the same way we trust essential workers
to provide the care they give to us
our families trust us to give them a
safe and protected home
today's episode is brought to you by
clorox when it counts trust clorox
our community here is trust clorox to
keep places like hospitals grocery
stores
disinfected so i know i too can trust
clorox to provide my home with a safe
environment at home we can all enjoy
that is why i trust clorox regular
bleach by mixing up one-third cup of
clorox regular bleach with one gallon of
water
when used as directed on hard non-porous
surfaces it kills
99.9 percent of germs and bacteria on a
variety of surfaces
from our kitchen floors to counters to
bathroom tabs to of course
laundry wipes i know i can count on
clorox disinfecting products to give
myself and my family the best home we
deserve
i use clorox disinfecting products at my
home to keep my floors clean
my door handles clean and just
everything clean because i got a little
puppy running around for
me it's important to share with loved
ones and the public in general how they
can give the most care for their loved
ones because
when it counts trust chloros feel good
so may you released a book last year um
a woman makes a national i thought i
would show you some
the japan cover the turkey cover and i
know
i have all different covers i know yes
they've been translated in so many
different languages like and i keep
seeing those like every word but
every every month you have a new
announcement it's been translated into
this language been translated into this
language that's amazing
so did you do the whole did you do the
whole tour like the book tour with that
well i can only do it virtually now are
they all
in their countries and and we did have
some
international tour book launches uh
booked and of course everything was
cancelled
so it's all virtual but we're doing a
lot of interviews i mean sometimes it
would be something like
um germany in the morning and russia at
lunchtime
and china in the afternoon and south
africa at night
i mean you know so you can do
a woman makes a plan you've got into
some really intimate
and personal details in that book
um mainly also giving encouragement to
girls in
abusive relationships so
like how deep did you have to go while
you were writing that and what was that
experience like
well first of all i was told to to to
dictate my
my life and then uh and
so that i have some advice to give from
every section of my life
and so the adventures in the kalahari
desert that was easy going to study
for a bachelor of science degree in
afrikaans which means i had to learn a
new language that was hard but still
i did it and then in my abusive marriage
i did a chapter on that
and then after i read it i said to the
editor please take that chapter out
but my children elon kimball and tosca
individually had said to me you talk
about your struggles
because you've been perfect on instagram
and
and and people will think oh first of
all you're just you know your life has
just been easy
and so i i kept that in but i wasn't
happy to keep it in because you don't
like to share abuse you're not with
anybody
and my two brothers and my twin sister
said we had no
idea what you were going through because
we just knew we couldn't see you because
you were so busy
but i was bruised and also i wasn't
allowed to see my family or any friends
and that you'll find is common
in a in an abusive relationship and i'm
insulted every day
you know and you're ugly you're stupid
you're boring that's why we have no
friends
but he would insult me in public as well
and only when i ran away with the three
kids
you'd run away but you're terrified too
because he's made a lot of threats if
you should ever leave
and then you uh you run away and you
find out
everybody just was was so happy for me
and they all um uh they just said wow
you know we couldn't come near you
because
he was so insulting and so
i i escaped and i escaped with my life
with my children and then he sued me for
nine years after that because
you know i'm a bad mother and and then
i only when i moved to toronto could he
stop suing me
and then my funds were blocked so i had
to get find a rent controlled apartment
i mean this was all in my book
and we were happy and people saying why
why am i so happy
you know sleeping on the carpet with my
kids
in a in a rent-controlled apartment and
it's because he couldn't reach me there
so other women are not as fortunate as
me i was fortunate in that
i am had a out of occupation i was a
dietitian i couldn't rely on modeling
although it continued surprisingly
and so i was a dietitian and
enough to do my master of science
degrees with both of them
they had scholarships for me so i didn't
have to
pay any money for it because i didn't
have any money for that
and then also um some
some men are even more vicious
and will come after a woman physically
and and hurt them
so some women will be in a worse
position than me that they can't support
their children
um so but i could only share what i
well what i went through but the the dms
on instagram and on twitter and that
when they read my book they say
i'm in that position i'm getting out now
or i was in that position
and i'm now inspired that life can get
better
it's incredible it's crazy how sharing
your story
can inspire and help so many people i'm
so happy you kept that chapter in there
you know yeah i'm sure you changed a lot
of lives with that
yes and uh yeah so there is hope but you
you can't have
so when when people are saying to
actresses
uh that you you're going to get old and
you won't
have any work you got to change those
people
because that's not nice and you you got
to mix with nice people
you change that and you make sure you
mix with nice people
because there's many men who support
women so it's not just
um but there are many men who will keep
them down
and you've got to be in charge of your
own life and i think you two are doing a
great job
a great job thank you
hey that was so like i mean
thank you so much for sharing that i
know it's in your book as well but like
to be
able to talk about it you know and
uh continuously share that trust me
that's like
it's really put me into you know a zone
as well where
you know i mean i'm sure all of us have
been through some kind of trauma
or just some kind of you know downfall
or just like a really bad time in our
in our lives and you know what when you
when you hear it from someone who that
you who you look up to and you're like
okay wait but she's also been through
something like that
um but look at her now and she's just
like she's wonderful and positive and
pushing through um it really just makes
you
you know think how strong we all are i
think a lot of us forget that we really
forget our
internal strength and the minute the day
we realize it
you know things change and i love people
who actually speak about these things
um because you know i can i've been
through certain situations in my life
and the thing is when you don't really
have someone to you know to discuss it
with
or you know someone's people are not
speaking up about it you yourself don't
know what to do
and um and you hide and you you don't
know where to turn
um but then it's like you know when you
when you actually have people making a
conversation about it you're like okay
wait a minute there are other people out
there
and um i'm so happy that you know like
you're you're actually talking about it
because it will
and it has already but it will change so
many more lives
um you will still go through many stages
where your
internal confidence is knocked out of
you you will go through it
but as you get older which i'm saying
aging is great
and you've been to it and you can you
can see
okay i'm in a really sad unhappy
situation i'm being knocked down they
trying to take away my confidence
and yeah then you can get out of it
quicker and
i mean i stayed in bad relationships and
bad situations
too long because i thought i could
change people
and i thought i could make them
understand that i'm a good person i'm
very talented or i'm very
intelligent or i'm very you know
whatever
nice person or whatever and they would
still pull you down
so um you need to i every day a guy i
dated i would help him with his business
i would promo
you know really do good things for him
and they
never i mean there's only one guy i
actually dated he was my german
boyfriend he
sent me to the good institutes of econ
mean i'm picking up on a little bit
because johannes is from
austria so he speaks german so i'm like
oh i know what it is
also because i like to speak for i
studied french at school and then i kept
it going
and because i can africa i'm fluent in
afrikaans which is very similar to dutch
which also helped me when i studied
german because the verb is at the end of
the sentence
that's a hard hard hard language
yeah i it's just it's so different but
i i think what's so cool is that
nobody told you to learn these things
nobody
was like oh send me off to private
school and get her educated and all
these things
but you do that on your own because
you're curious and curiosity can be a
great thing it's actually one of the
best things
and you taught yourself you found ways
to learn new things and i think that's
what's always
made you able to grow and get out of
things and
you know be where you are today yes i
when i i'm
terrified of boredom so even when the
lockdown happened i said i'm going to be
watching german movies and french movies
and dutch movies
keep my languages going but then of
course
then i got a young assistant to put me
on tik tok and then
then she did exercise videos with me and
then my book went international so
i have had a very busy and very excited
about it
but otherwise i don't know how i could
have you know kept myself
going um mentally you know
but um do you you also have a um
um a non-profit you actually have two
you have
the big green and you have
dress for success which i think is
amazing
right so big green and and amanda really
was
a a great supporter of that week where
they go to underserved schools where
children don't have access to fruits and
vegetables
and they have containers where the
children can plant seeds they teach them
i mean wow i was teaching them to plant
eats and amazing they walk with them and
then they grow
the vegetables or fruit and then they
pull the carrots out of a
dirt and they get so excited about
vegetables
and then they taught how to prepare it
and eat it and then they can take home
to their
to their family and teach them about
nutrition so it was
magnificent it was 650 gardens and and
kimball my youngest son wanted to do
um a thousand gardens but then of course
lockdown all the schools were closed the
beginning of it
oh no you guys didn't stop
you guys didn't stop there though
lockdown happened and you're like all
right here's some at-home kids
amazing now but it's so funny amount of
the first time i met me
um oh yeah yeah wait hold on when did
yeah when did you two meet because this
is true the funniest
the funniest thing is and luckily thank
god for instagram we were able to
reconnect on instagram
but the first time i met her it was at
this um
uh it was at this fashion event wait it
was imran
yeah it was a dinner it was a dinner for
um
the business of fashion and it was in
l.a and i was i was in italy at the time
and two of my friends
they i mean they run it they're from
mumbai and london
and they said hey just come down for
dinner and that's when i met me and
may i remember exactly what you were
wearing
it was a beautiful purple outfit
and you know you just stood out like in
the crowd
and i had i was like i was staring at
you because i was so mesmerized i was
like wow she's so beautiful and look at
her
outfit and that purple and her hair and
her face
and then when we got introduced they're
like oh it's maine musk and i was like
oh my god this is so cool
and i remember we had such a such an um
a lovely conversation like from that
minute like i was just i was super
inspired you had no idea who
i was and you know but you were still
giving your time to me and and
chatting with me and just discussing we
were discussing so many things i
remember
what life is you know in mumbai and and
and then
i mean i i didn't see me for like about
a year
and um we just you know i reconnected
with her on instagram
i was just you know i was like oh i
wonder how she's doing and i was seeing
news about your book as well
and i was like i have to connect with
her again and then i just think social
media is such an amazing thing
you know me and amanda met on on
instagram and i think it's just such a
great way to like build connections and
build relationships and reconnect as
well
so yeah and that's that's our love story
i love it and it's all like
obviously may you can tell we're such
huge fan girls of you yeah
i think everything we say we're like
it's it's ridiculous
you would be scared of a woman in her
70s i mean
it's just weird but then that time
that's what i found when i
work with younger people is that they
they are so
they just want to absorb everything i
was saying and they kept on saying
you've got to write a book you've got to
write a book and then the followers on
instagram said you've got to write a
book and
and that's why i wrote it but again i
didn't really think i had a story
but if people relate to different
stories in my book
there's 28 little chapters absolutely i
think it's
a lot of times you tell like you know
you have conversations about your own
life your own story and it's so like
old news to you because and you're like
whatever about it
but yeah it's surprising how impactful
it can be to other people
because and that's you being humble also
by the way i mean you've been through
a lot more than a lot of people have in
their own lives but
yeah i'm happy you're sharing it
just that you you need to try new things
you need to get into a better situation
that's why i'm moving back to new york i
mean
i'm so excited for that content by the
way
yeah oh yeah new york content i feel
like
when i i feel like the whole look today
is very in new york too
i'm feeling like you're ready you know
you're ready for it we have a fun thing
that we do
it's a random fun facts so
we're gonna go through those really
quickly i bet you may i bet you may
already know us all about them should we
like yeah no
obviously yeah that would be that would
be a good
uh a good drinking game how many does
they
already know all right number one
when a woman is speaking to a man she
finds attractive
she naturally speaks in a higher pitch
ooh i didn't know that
i don't know that i think about it now
that i think about it it's true
well hi how are you oh yeah
i mean but if that's what it is then
yeah but yeah i feel like you're an
exception because you're
yeah your accent is just so like
soothing
and it's just like good the way it is so
you just i think i think amanda it's the
other way around if like when a guy
speaks to me
his voice becomes a higher pitch boom
that's what it is
it's a reverse with me it's a reverse
all right number two number two newborn
babies have a natural reflex
reflex to swim for the first four to six
months of their lives this instinct
then disappears and must be re-taught
ooh i well yeah i know that babies are
natural swimmers but i didn't realize
that it
it goes after a couple of months and
then they have to relearn it
oh sorry i want to know did you ever
take your
because have you seen those videos of
when people throw their babies
in the pool and they just like bob back
up no i didn't
do that
apparently it looks terrifying but a lot
of people do it apparently because
i guess they like it just teach if they
fall in the pool it teaches them but it
looks like
traumatizing but also i
i just see those videos and i'm like is
that normal is that what mine
it looks kind of scary i didn't know
about it in the time don't forget
oh yeah no yeah i don't think i i don't
think i had the guts to throw my kid in
his pool
even if i knew it was a swimmer i'd be
like no
let's not do this it's funny how like
when
you're not a mom yet you literally know
close to nothing about babies and how
they work
at least me like anytime i see my french
kids i'm like oh like
can they speak yet no they're um six
months old
like no they can't speak yet i'm like
okay
okay i feel like that goes back to
education though like you educate
yourself about the things that like
you need in your life at the time or
that you're like aiming towards
and for me that's kind of like my
thought process when it comes to babies
like i'll learn when i get there oh yeah
is when i was 21 i had
a job that i had to give lectures on
infant feeding
and i remember talking is giving the
talk at the hospital and the matron
the head of the nurses she says you
haven't even had a child what do you
know and i was following research work
and then i had my three kids and
actually talk about their what i fed
them as well
and uh you're right you really need to
have a child before you can talk about
infant feeding if you can't just follow
the science
yeah i see okay that's good
i don't feel as bad no so thanks
well our next fun fact is the desire to
eat or crunch ice can be a sign of iron
deficiency
hmm well as a dietitian it's called pica
because when you eat something that's
not really edible
and i didn't come across it much and i
was in private practice for 45 years
with uh
with people with eating disorders
i didn't come across anyone who had
picker in regarding
chewing ice because if you chewing as it
might be to lose
weight and then you actually are not
eating iron deficient food
iron containing foods again i
haven't come across that much have you
come across it
um no i mean i'm sure that my iron
levels
i can get them to a better place and i
never chew ice
but maybe i'm an exception yeah but that
is true actually i think like oh but
there are some people who
love just you know they have this thing
my dog
is he low in iron i think we should
check up on him
with vegans you know you the the two
main
nutrients you have to be concerned about
is iron and vitamin b12
but i'm sure you're figuring that out
too because you look very
healthy and happy yeah well thank you
i do supplement with b12 and d3
also like my family for some reason were
all
just get deficient in vitamin d which is
interesting we're in florida but um i
guess we just don't absorb it
that's the same thing in india like a
lot of people here do have a vitamin d
deficiency as well um so and i i
and we're like you know where the sun is
and out and about
but um yeah it is something that's very
common here it's a very common
deficiency here as well um but
um why yeah that's so crazy when i look
at the research work on vitamin
d deficiencies i find the values are
different and so the
i don't i'm not very concerned about
vitamin d deficiency
because if you're eating well you're
getting in all your nutrients in
they're finding that with some people
who are
have underlying factors like they are
obese and their vitamin d
is low then there is an increased risk
of
risk of certain other diseases but the
thing is
if you're eating badly you're not going
to get much vitamin d now
i drink milk you know so that's got
vitamin d
it's fortified with vitamin d but many
cereals are fortified with
vitamin d2 and you can just
you know have fatty fish or other foods
that will contain
but i still i'm not i don't know if
the measurements they're saying is
important is
is really um i don't know if
evidence is there yet so i wouldn't
worry especially if in
india where you are in the sun it would
be
um unusual for you to have a vitamin d
deficiency
i wonder how often they change those
value charts
of like it all depends on the research
and then the research reaches the
doctors
uh or else the doctors start believing
things they don't really study nutrition
i remember about 20 years ago everybody
was
all the doctors were recommending
vitamin e now you never hear about
vitamin e because now
it's true yeah and then also if you take
a vitamin d
supplement it doesn't necessarily
increase your vitamin d it depends on
the supplement
and supplements are not regulated
well it's it's so hard that's why you
need a dietitian because
yeah yeah because trying to do that
through a google search you can get a
lot of
misinformation yeah yeah
wait we gotta hire may um if one day
we'll be able to get diet when will that
day come
yeah today let's utilize it now
but our next one i'll let you go ahead
jacqueline
all right cool okay so
dogs evolved puppy eyes to manipulate
humans
that puppy dog look that your canine
companion gives you is completely
adorable
totally intentional and something that
they've developed since they've become
man's best friend
in 2019 a study was there in the
proceedings of national academy of
sciences explaining that domesticated
dogs have evolved
to have facial muscles around their eyes
that wild wolves lack oh
i actually knew this i did actually saw
this yeah
in a in a documentary i was watching
just about the evolution and
of everything and how you know they
like they were they just evolved from
from wolves but only because
when they would see these nomadic humans
they realized that you know
humans realized that wait a minute if we
kept these wolves or dogs around
they would actually protect us because
they would like bark and stuff like
there were other things or you know
other
animals and so what they would do is in
response to that they would like to
throw some food at them
and so the dogs realized oh we'd get
food but
but they like it if we protect them and
so they just evolved into like keep you
know they just wanted to always protect
us
um and they evolved from that and the
wild ones like the world and stuff we
just didn't get it who didn't evolve
into that kind of knowledge
they just stayed wild and wolfy and the
other ones the
domesticated ones you know started
becoming domesticated and friendlier and
friendlier and friendlier they just
realized that
that's going to get us food and that's
going to help us with our survival
so um they were really smart they're a
lot smarter than we think
what type of woman this one is very
smart
he's a rescue so he's a multi-step
but of course i call him a multi-poo
because those are expensive dogs
depends on the conversation yeah and
she does control my life and yes
and he's been they all do the best
friend during the quarantine
animals are literally the best talk
about like stress reliever and i think
this is why a lot of people
got them in quarantine and gave them a
home
because it's just endless love and
i love that i always say if you if
you're not successful
at dating get a dog because when you
come home and you're
it's late and you don't look so great
he's still happy to see you
he's the happiest i mean if you're
dating they're always
what yeah falco's whole butt
just goes boom side to side whenever i
walk in the door and just he can't
control his body he's just so happy
yeah johannes thank you for your time
but you're no longer needed
yeah oh by the way um
you'll you'll you'll like this mate you
guys can't
i hope he's not in here i got um
can you hear me yeah okay i got uh
johannes a tesla for christmas
wow yeah stick
he's like oh my god he's gonna love that
yeah yeah he's gonna be he's been
wanting one forever
okay i'm gonna stop talking about it
and he's getting oh he's gonna love it
you're gonna love it
i know yes it's for me too
yeah amanda secretly gets it for herself
hey i got it for you johannes yeah yeah
oh i'll drive yeah i gotta stop i don't
i don't want to ruin it all right the
next one is
or our last one is the heads of easter
island have bodies the iconic iconic
stone heads protruding from the ground
on east island are familiar to most but
many don't realize
what lies beneath the surface in 1919
archaeologists studying
the hundreds of stone statues on the
pacific island
excavated two of the figures revealing
full torsos which measures large as high
as 33 feet
wow oof this is scary our earth is wild
yeah how it just like continues
aliens yeah for real
have you watched um i forget what the
documentary is it's about the ocean and
it just
how deep it goes down and it's like
mount ever taller than mount everest
down there and then there's another
layer of water that's a different
uh consistency that only other animals
can live down there it's like literal
aliens
yeah it's so crazy we have no idea what
we're even like
like i think not even like half of what
our planet has in store
we have absolutely no idea it's just you
know there's so much undiscovered world
that i mean with that may will you be
going
um to space anytime soon or if you have
the opportunity would you go
well i don't think i'll be number one on
the list first of all i would have to
train for two years to be an astronaut
you know yes you could
yeah but you will and then i would like
to go
when it's kind of there's a first class
and not an economy so that i can you
know have a lovely living room to sit in
and and have a you know meal served or
something
you know at the moment they just sit in
their suits so
let's just see and then on the other
side i would like
them to be a lovely home for me and uh
so i think that could be a take a while
because
they would have to first of all get all
the all the equipment there and then all
the
astronauts would have to be engineers
and build me a lovely home
so i don't think i'm a priority on their
schedule
especially people you
yeah yeah maybe yeah they're going to
wait a little bit for you but it's okay
i'll go on the trip you're on because
that sounds great
yeah yeah we'll be having fun
and to wrap this up we're just going to
go into some quick questions
that people inquired about you wanting
to know more about you from your fans
so what is the most important thing a
woman can do to mean
teen a youthful appearance and stay out
of the sun
don't smoke eat very healthily
and be happy every morning because a
smile is the most beautiful thing
oh that's beautiful i i agree
i completely agree all right that was
lovely um
tell us something you like to do for fun
me
oh i left to go to parties i love to
meet new people
i love to travel so those are all things
that uh have been limiting this year
and uh soon i hope to see both of you
we'll all sit together to do one of
these
of course i would like please go to
mumbai
yeah i agree let's let's choose a city
let it be my mind
you guys come here done
don't tell me exactly what
is your exercise routine and how often
do you do it
well my exercise routine used to be the
exercise bike
and then the weights and the and
stretches and then
of course the gyms are closed so i walk
my dog three times a day
and uh but he he he snaps a lot so you
really don't get much exercise but then
i
watch and exercise vis uh videos like um
be moved dancer and i love they do
gentle exercises they don't
it's not like core strength things i've
did that
in the past but then you start hurting
yourself
so i don't myself to get hurt anymore
i'm not pushing myself that hard
i do follow even some fabulous dancing
routines i mean i'm very bad at it but
it gets me
moving and then i have streaks because i
do on the carpet and weights
i want to see those tick tocks i'm tired
some days
i'm lazy yeah can you can you please
upload your dance routines on tech talk
yeah i would like to see those
okay yeah now and nodding she'll think
oh yeah
they will be funny but thank you
i'll i'll send you some bollywood
choreography as well
yes i'd love that you guys can do duets
yeah yeah i will do how i do it starting
which is
terrible and then let's see if i carry
on practicing
if i get better of course you will oh my
gosh we'll send you we'll certainly be
outfit and everything to go along with
it
i mean yes i was thinking
and lovely sorry and that i don't i
haven't got something like that
oh that would look so stunning on you oh
this is the best idea
ever okay get to work on that ring
first thing done you just send all of us
the same
outfits and then we can all do it and do
it
and edit it together okay i'm working on
this this is my next project
yeah i mean not that you don't have
enough on your plate already
but just go ahead not that to it that'd
be good yeah i don't care
this is the most important thing right
now what was that me
yeah same outfits same routine yeah
and then when we get together we can do
it together but in the meantime we'll
just work on it
well thank you so much mae for being on
today
and taking time out of your schedule to
hang out with us love catching up with
you both always
every single time i can and and thank
you guys for listening to the feels good
podcast
make sure you check out may get her book
and make sure you subscribe to her on
every single platform there is follow
her on tick tock because she has dances
coming soon
oh yes thank you may so much sending
lots of love
and wishes your way my plan your
wonderful work
inspiring many people worldwide that's
important mm-hmm
bye guys